okay next one
um uh hosted buyer meetings on a plane
B2B decision makers get a free vacation
if they agree to have X number of
conversations on a flight it's like the
timeshare idea it's like so you get a
free flight uh but you're gonna get on a
plane a full of vendors it's like that
movie Snakes on a Plane instead of
snakes it's just B2B software vendors
just waiting to just barrage you for for
the next seven hours on your way to Maui
[Music]
so here's I'm gonna tell you about
something that's interesting there's a
guy who I love and his name's Anand dude
uh he started CB insights you know him
yeah listens to the Pod love the guy
yeah he's a great guy he's one of my
good friends and I was thinking about
this so there's a lot of things that
second time or third time entrepreneurs
think about that mostly first-time
entrepreneurs don't think about one of
them being distribution so they'll think
like oh I'm just gonna make a cool
product and they'll somehow get into
people's hands that's false you gotta
have marketing baked in or like it's got
to be part of like the ideation phase
marketing the second thing is pricing uh
they think oh I'll just charge five
dollars a month and I'll get like
millions of people to buy this and then
you actually start doing it and you're
like wow this is incredibly challenging
to get thousands or tens of thousands
let alone millions of people to buy
something that's really hard and so I've
been thinking about that pricing thing
so things that fit my wants and my needs
and my skill sets so for example content
there's industry dive which probably
only has five or ten million people a
month reading their website but they
make [__] for like people who own
grocery stores like like content for
people in grocery stores versus BuzzFeed
which makes stuff for stay-at-home moms
who like cat videos BuzzFeed worth 100
million Industry Drive does the exact
same thing way smaller audience makes or
sold recently for 500 or 600 million
dollars so like I've been thinking about
like those that price just like that
that the different ways of packaging and
so a non from CB insights he's got this
company that's brand new
it's only 90 days old it's been way
low-key and under the under wraps and I
recently discovered it and I asked him
so it's called yardstick so go to
yardstick.com and tell me what you see
it's called the yardstick so it's the
word yard like a backyard and then stick
is s-t-i-q
he's getting a little cute on us uh
let's see okay so yardstick powered by
CV insights learn what software buyers
really think about their vendors great
time right great headline yeah um and
then it says access thousands of
analysts LED conversations with software
buyers to quickly understand pricing
competition evaluation criteria and
subscription and satisfaction so
basically they interview software buyers
and they get the scoop on how do you
really feel about X tool and then they
summarize it so that you can
you can see how other people think about
this tool before you buy it exactly
that's it and they charge like something
they charge yeah it's really smart and
I'll explain how this works but they
charge like 30 or 40 000 a year for this
and I think this could be 100 million
dollar a year business and they're just
not I'm I'm downplaying but right now
the MVP is just interviewing people and
showing transcripts eventually I'm sure
this is really smart I remember you
talked about this back in the day
because there's that website what is it
G2 crowd yes exactly and um there's
basically like software is a massive
category and people are like oh which
CRM should I use and it's like oh you
know it's HubSpot fighting with 10 other
people to try to be the answer to that
question and so reviews is always this
thing that people are trying to like I
think people in general want the idea of
a review but it's hard to trust reviews
nowadays you don't know if the reviews
are faked uh you don't know if they're
from people like you who have the same
problems as you uh and the website like
you know G2 crowd and these other ones
they're pretty bad and I've seen it I've
seen several people try to create a new
software review site to compete with
them and they have to do two things one
they have to actually be better at the
reviews and two they have to rank higher
in SEO for when somebody searches for
you know whatever X tool alternative or
what's the best which is hard no sales
tool for me to use and it's really hard
to beat their SEO and so they're finding
a very uphill battle this I think is
smart for two reasons one they already
have a bunch of customers that they
could just sell this sell into with this
two the idea of instead of saying okay
well whoever reviews it hopefully
they're good reviews they're like no
we're just gonna hire people to do these
conversations and like the math works
out if we get these Brands to say what
they think about these tools you know we
might only need to invest I don't know
two hundred thousand dollars into the to
the collection of that data and that
gives us like like a better review so a
better uh content system
and what you've nailed everything and
there's a third thing though which is
basically G2 or um softwarereviews.com
or a lot of these websites the way they
typically work is they give an affiliate
fee or some type of like advertisement
fee they they collect that from the
brand who wants to advertise on the
website which means they have to go and
get traffic and they've got to convince
these Brands to give money whereas this
business yardstick it does exactly what
I said before it changes the way they
package it and so they just go no you're
the customer you're going to read this
and you're going to get value from this
you're giving us 30 grand a year and so
we're just going to make [__] for you
and it's just that's our that's our
that's our exchange and so that's what
we're gonna do and so basically the
background behind this business is uh
this is something that I didn't know
about until recently and probably you
didn't either because we both had small
companies and so a small company in this
definition is anything that's below a
billion dollars in in market cap or
value meaning typically the people who
buy this [__] have 500 employees and the
reason that's important is when you buy
a software provider or you buy a CRM or
you buy like some type of um what's it
called where you uh like uh your
customer like you do give customer
feedback like or you uh like interact
with your customers and your customer
service agents use it doing business I
don't know customer happiness I don't
you know whatever like the software is
like a Zen desk or something like that
so but like picking the wrong software
if you are a 500 company it will cost
you like so much money and so you have
to do actually a fair bit amount of
research including like who invested in
this company so I know they're not even
going to go out of business and I never
even a million years thought about that
I'm like dude I'm just going to Google
like what's better Gusto or zenefits and
like we'll just pick one and then we'll
switch if it sucks and so what yardstick
is doing is they actually have just it's
Anon and seven other employees are the
early people starting this company and
they basically just ask like seven
questions to people who have bought
software uh in the last two years and
they say like who else did you consider
who'd you pick what price did you pay
would you renew what's your customer
satisfaction and then um the people who
purchased this yardstick product are
either investment bankers so people who
are like making investment decisions
from the public markets or or private
markets and they want to know what the
customer satisfaction is or people who
are going out and buying software and
they could see these other reviews and
it's just like a really interesting
business because there's there's a
company's like GLG you know GLG it's
like you get paid two grand an hour GLG
calls back in the day yeah you get paid
two grand an hour to like answer
questions but that's one to one and so
what they're saying is like no we're not
gonna do one-to-one but we'll just make
it so you can just read like dozens and
dozens of interviews so anyway
interesting company for all everything I
said but secondly it's an interesting
company because this business is only 90
days old and I think if you go and sign
up for their email list now it's kind of
like you can watch like a big business
being built in real time
yeah this is really good like I'm
jealous I didn't think of this idea
um
I kind of wish he had just done this
outside of CB insights I feel like this
could have been his next hit I think
it's going to be as CB insights so I
think there's
a slight you know although it's good to
be able to sell into those same
customers I think it would have been
worth it to uh you know spin this out
but you know that's a that's a com more
complicated decision by the way
this guy Anan he has a giant list of
startup ideas have you seen this no
where
I'm trying to find the list I remember
seeing it on
um Twitter one day but uh here well why
look for a second the background behind
a nod is he started CB insights they're
close to 100 million in Revenue he's
kind of a [__] in a really good way
for example he signs he he writes their
daily newsletter and he signs the
newsletter with I love you or in his
Twitter file it's profile it says please
sign up for CB insights I owe people
money and like he is like like kind of
like a cheeky like mischievous guy and
very very likable and that's and his
content's amazing and so that's anon's
really interesting if you if you want to
know what speaks to our heart
you got to be
somebody who's trying to do something so
you got to be ambitious or successful in
some way and the second thing is
a little bit of a [__] so you know
like have that
I don't like to eat my wings without
sauce you got to have a little dipping
sauce to your personality if you're
gonna if you're gonna get me on board
and he's got the sauce all right so let
me tell you some of these ideas so I
don't have the full list I remember
seeing this like a year ago or something
like that
um we should get them on the Pod but let
me just read a couple of the ideas that
were tweeted out from this list okay so
first one Tough Mudder for kids so
here's what he says really any sort of
manufactured adversity for semi-afluent
or affluent kids parents talk about
wanting their kids to have perspective
resilience and reduce their entitlement
and get them off screens
um Tough Mudder for kids super high
margin unsure if uh
you know unsure exactly how it worked
but money to be made for sure okay dude
Spartan Race is now Spartan races I'm
signing up for one they actually have a
kids version right now tiny Spartans I
don't know if that's what it's called
but you know we can pretend uh
startup idea Duolingo for teaching
Finance or accounting teach the
principles of accounting or Finance via
gamified Duolingo Style app what do you
give that one uh yeah that's cool okay
next one
um uh hosted buyer meetings on a plane
B2B decision makers get a free vacation
if they agree to have this number of
conversations on a flight it's like the
timeshare idea it's like so you get a
free flight uh but if you're gonna get
on a plane a full of vendors it's like
that movie Snakes on a Plane there's
snakes it's just B2B software vendors
just waiting to just barrage you for the
next seven hours of Maui and just tons
of coke and just everything that like a
45 year old guy named Todd who wears
tight blue jeans and brown shoes
whatever they need like yeah this is
Jennifer she wants you to call her Jenny
and she happens to like you yeah
I think it's actually uh I think you
actually could build a business that way
if you sign up for a free trial you get
to go to First Class that'd be great uh
yeah this is actually a kind of a genius
idea okay here we go buyable Google doc
travel itineraries so friends often
share their travel plans via Google Docs
you know here's what I did in Iceland
um since they're friends I Chester
judgment
um you know the idea would be let me
just buy the whole itinerary with the
buy now button my vacation plan is done
awesome quick reaction yeah okay
um that's a small business but cool
win-loss reporting for employee hiring
and nutrition so when somebody doesn't
accept your job offer the service would
would dig in and find out the real
reasons why when somebody service digs
in and finds the real reason why it
would maybe anonymize or synthesize the
insights over time today the process is
very ad hoc that's a great idea that's a
great idea that is a really good idea uh
wow that's a that's a solid one okay
uh here's a that's a solid one but more
fun the Nike of baby diapers
so create high performance premium
diapers use sodium polyacrylate to make
them super absorbent like astronaut
diapers other Tech to increase Comfort
make cleanup easier why because parents
spend a stupid amount of money on their
kids okay dude anytime anytime you say
it's a Nike or something it's like when
I see a restaurant in the side of road
it says world's greatest coffee or like
the best pie in town I automatically buy
it that's my rule if it says it's the
world's greatest if you're just bold
enough to think that I I'm gonna try it
I bet dude I had the same realization
yesterday where I was listening to some
talk where Johnny Ive was talking and
um and I I knew somebody who met Johnny
Ive like used to hang out with Johnny
Ive regularly they like live near each
other in San Francisco and I was like oh
what's Johnny I've like for those who
don't know he's basically the the head
designer at Apple for like all the great
products iPod yeah whatever Macintosh uh
you know iPhone all that good stuff so
this guy's like the basically the
greatest product designer in the world
he's the guy Steve Jobs trusted the most
at Apple
I was like what's he like they're like
oh you know he's kind of like you would
expect he's like you know he's he's got
a sort of a dry but but funny
personality he's a he's a pretty focused
individual like he's not like effing
around a whole lot
um you know he works really hard and um
they'd be like yeah they've come to me
they're like yeah Johnny had an idea I
was like oh my God what's this Johnny I
have idea no I don't know specifics this
was like eight years ago but they just
said that for every idea but it'd be
like
a closet that's beautifully designed
[Laughter]
I'd be like you know what you guys
should do like I was giving somebody
advice the other day I was like you know
in your when you guys is an econ brand I
was like when you send your package you
should put in there just like beautiful
pamphlet just looks super well done that
just will make somebody they'll read it
they'll know your story but just just a
beautiful pamphlet and then and I
realized I was like wow if you just say
like a beautiful thing a beautiful and
then just like generic thing and say
just super well done the idea goes from
like a whatever idea to like that's a
great idea yeah I can see it's like when
honestly it's not totally BS there is
something to it if you said like you
know let's just make like a really like
just a hilarious YouTube video
it's like actually that is the correct
strategy
you know but there's not much more to it
is it the question can you can you do
something that's actually beautiful or
really well done or really funny but
honestly that's not a bad business plan
for most things to just say just a
beautifully done just all the details
nailed
it's like when Andrew Wilkinson Andrew
Wilkinson says we try to buy wonderful
companies right and like our beautiful
businesses we want to buy beautiful
businesses like a job board yeah like
wonderful you're right that is it's
wonderful
he's like okay we're gonna bake this
cookie but it's just gonna melt in your
mouth and you're like okay all right all
right I'm in it's like you know
otherwise it's just a cookie
and so I think there's something to this
but um all right I'm gonna keep going by
the way I feel like I'm reading this
guy's diary and just you know I feel I
feel wrong just taking all these startup
ideas here so rapid fire this could be
like on 12 episodes of content for us
but I'm gonna don't read it let's just
steal it
well I know but I'm like I want to just
use them all now on a binge eat this
whole like tub of ice cream right here
let me give you a couple more
um
happycam a highlight reel of the best
moments of your life how a wearable
camera that records audio and video only
when you're laughing it captures the
conversation of who you're with and
great moments all right fictitious even
the great ones are gonna miss once in a
while yeah
double balance here
um
okay how about
let me pull up another one
okay how about this
um
he also wrote bad startup ideas I think
so bad but sexy so startup ideas that
suck you in but they're actually bad
startup ideas here we go yeah personal
CRM
always a bad one preach into the choir
yeah there's recommendations
well in most cases it's bad but hey look
that's what you mean yeah
um it's something going to be like a
college campus like Craigslist and then
like laundry on like uh delivery laundry
here's one what are my friends up to
right now apps these apps I promise you
hey what if your friend was two blocks
away you didn't know this with this app
you could have met up with them no wrong
dude by the way did you know that girls
share their location on their iPhone
with other girls like my wife does this
with her friends did you know people are
like safety purposes
I don't know why they do that but like I
was out with like my wife and a bunch of
her friends and they all did the same
thing with themselves like that group of
friends and other people like they know
their where their real-time location is
at all times hold on wait
a car my friends going to the restroom
but she wanted somebody to go with her
I don't even know where that feature is
on a phone yeah I don't know you click a
thing and it says like share location
for an hour or share indefinitely yeah
it seems like a trap uh yeah it's not
gonna happen to-do list software yep
that's one classic strip idea that
everybody does
um glass door for VCS a website that
reads VCS nobody really cares very much
about VCS they're infrequent decisions
for most entrepreneurs they'll take
money from who they can get yeah um in
most cases Founders are lucky enough to
have a good choice they probably already
know who's good
bad startup ideas but he's got a bunch
here I'm not gonna we should have him on
yeah the guy's interesting he's pretty
he's earned his he's earned his spot for
sure I forgot to remind you these last
few times you being The Listener about
our gentleman's agreement so like uh
have you ever yes uh there's like have
you ever gone to 7-Eleven and you've
seen like uh like an Alzheimer's or like
a sick children's like bowl and you like
leave a quarter and you take a piece of
candy right so that that whole thing
works and they use this thing called an
honor System a gentleman's agreement
where you put down a quarter and you
take a piece of candy and it just it
just works that's kind of what our
podcast is like a little bit with
subscribing to our YouTube channel so
Sean and I spent all this time we talk
about stuff constantly about what we're
gonna do on the Pod I live in Epic life
actually just so I can talk about it on
the Pod I dedicate my life to this and
all I want in exchange is not even a
quarter it's just for you to click
subscribe on YouTube so if you're
listening to this on iTunes or Spotify
whatever just go to your YouTube and
just click subscribe that's all we want
because that helps the algorithm we get
a little bit higher and then we'll just
it helps our ego I mean that's really
good today if you're making the choice
between Alzheimer's children and us make
the right choice choose us yeah it's
free it's crazy 60 of our YouTube views
come from people who don't subscribe
and that's crazy all I can ask them is
are you not entertained do you not want
more of this click subscribe all right
so that's that uh Gentleman's Agreement
reinforced and everyone's been doing it
lately so if you don't do it you're
gonna you'll look silly so I think you
should do it um all right okay I want to
talk about a different little Trend that
I've seen on Twitter and I call this
the guy Mafia and I saw that line I
thought that was really funny I mean I
would have called the guy Mafia just the
mafia but the guy Mafia well so what
what am I calling the guy Mafia you've
probably seen this trend like I feel
like it's kind of new but it's basically
a whole bunch of Twitter accounts that
are branded like
car dealership guy
mobile home park guy strip mall guy Self
Storage guy right there's like and
they're basically just saying it's an
anonymous account so you don't know
who's behind it
the promise is basically hey I'm in I've
been in this this space for a while I
got you know I've been doing this for 10
20 years
I will share insights but also kind of
like industry secrets about the way our
industry works the you know the the
dirty laundry and
um these accounts are blowing up they
get really blowing up really fast I just
bought a car from car dealership guy did
you really know who this guy is I just
yeah I just dropped dude I almost bought
a car from him too I almost bought a car
from him too tell people who he is well
I don't want to say his identity he did
he did actually tell me his identity but
I know who he is too so he's car
dealership guy on Twitter he's basically
he's always just tweeting out about like
you know insights into the car market
right which I like following right
because I want to know about the car
market without doing any work so here's
one that he just tweeted he said Market
is literally flooded with Buicks they're
riding on car lots like trash you could
score a deal on these if you're willing
to suffer the embarrassment of being
seen in one Buicks are on 100 Buicks are
at 121 day supply for context Toyota is
less than 30 days Supply ridiculous the
simple people terms day supply means the
number of days it would take to deplete
the current new car inventory at the
current rate of sales and so immediately
I went let's go look at a Buick
I'm telling you right I I spent a lot of
money on a car uh through this guy that
I never saw so what he's doing with his
icons service which so okay let me give
you the full idea then then I'll break
it down but here's it will use him as an
example so it creates the car dealership
guy and I don't think he's been at it
for very long so uh let me pull up kind
of the the December 21.
so December 21 so that's one year
basically he added 93 000 followers in
the last 30 days
oh my God he's at 225 000 now
literally when we wrote this thing like
you know two days ago we did the
research release she was at 219. so like
two days he added six thousand followers
this guy's blowing up
um and what he's doing he's trading out
insights like okay yo here's what the
used car prices are doing here's what
the market is here's Which models and
makes or are hottest right now here's
why G wagons are selling for this and
here's where I think that's going here's
what's happening with auto loans and
here's what that means for the industry
all that good stuff okay so he gets the
following because he's putting out
interesting stuff
secondly
he then says okay well what do I do with
this what do I create a newsletter paid
Community you know people are like the
Sam and Sean Playbook you know they open
up their little like red red book and
they're like is this what I want to do
but actually he got some good advice
from a buddy of mine who said screw that
don't don't make a newsletter then try
to find ads or sponsors are paid he goes
just help people buy cars you're
building up a load of Trust on Twitter
people will buy cars from you in fact go
buy me a car so my buddy is like I want
to buy a Toyota Sequoia and I think
there's like Toyota Sequoia who's
telling me he's like some crazy things
where it hasn't been updated in like
15 or 18 years or something like that
like the last update was like in 2004 or
some [__] like that and there's like a
hundred thousand person waiting list for
the Toyota Sequoia some like crazy
number like that and he's like yeah but
I bet there's got to be one somewhere in
the country you know what I'll get I'll
buy in any color any goofy color and
this guy because car dealership guy is a
has a background as a dealer he can at
least we think access the car dealership
the car dealer Network so basically they
can buy cars they have like their own
little MLS system right so they can buy
cars out of auction and uh and what
that's how dealers acquire cars and then
they could sell those cars at a retail
market and so what he's doing is he's
just buying cars out of the auction
not really applying the retail markup
and just charging a flat fee as a
concierge for purchasing the vehicle
which we talked about before we talked
about negotiating a negotiating car
price as a service from a guy who like
knows the in and outs of car dealerships
and knows the time of month who to talk
to what to say things like that this is
like that but more in depth and so I
told the guy I was like hey um I want an
escalate and he's you wanted to escalate
I said I want to escalator by the way
hilarious thing I go I was like you know
let me just I was like I'm not gonna go
test drive these cars nothing so I was
like let me just go read the reviews
online real quick but if you search for
like reviews you get these like
it's like dude is this just like some
SEO optimized website so I go red right
let me go to Reddit and see what people
are saying
let me tell you how people on Reddit
feel about car dealerships the same way
that people in prison feel about
pedophiles like people on Reddit do not
like Escalades they are like dude I've
never met a non-jerk in an Escalade
right like smoking cigars
drug dealers and Desperate Housewives
and then I was like
hey guys category number three Indian
podcasters
here we go and so wait are you getting
the hybrid one or the electric one or
something like that no no no no you
gotta go full on but they have good you
know they have great self-driving
technology I actually looked at one too
I didn't do that much research to be
honest with you but um just got the the
big one so the the extended version so
anyways the my point is a lot of trust
but anyways bought a car with this guy
so dude you live in the suburbs of San
Francisco and you drive an Escalade you
are warping into something I don't know
exactly what it is but there's
definitely a stereotype that you're
fitting into you're like the Tony
Soprano of Danville
laughs
I can't believe that let me tell you
some of these other guys so we have
stripball guy who you know he's
basically I love him
little strip malls are like I don't know
I don't know what you would call it like
these little like b-class shopping
centers uh there's the wool uh franchise
wolf franchise wolf is a guy who talks
about buying franchises and what
franchise is doing oh crumble cookies
exploding like crazy here's what's going
on with that franchise that's a great
that's a great Niche to be in because
interested franchise buyers are super
super valuable that's that customer a
lead who's interested in buying a
franchise is worth tens of thousand
dollars to these uh companies
um secret CFO
another great name I didn't go with the
guy but I like secret CFO so I like
franchise wolf I like secret CFO these
are great names great Brands and I think
they work for a couple reasons what
about um the the watch guy I talked to
him I almost bought a watch from him he
just didn't even know about him yeah
there's a it's a he's it's a watch guy
it's called um
well I think just watch guy actually I
see a new one like every day right now
and by the way this is the watch guys is
gonna get flooded it's already getting
flooded because people see it now that
we're talking about it and breaking it
down
everybody who's like I am a dental
hygienist dental hygienist guy you know
like there's gonna be like just like a
ton of these coming out but honestly and
they all use cartoons as their Avatar by
the way I sent you in the Riverside chat
the luxury watch guy and he does the
exact same thing he goes here's what I'm
seeing this uh Rolex retails for 20 000.
it's an eight month wait and so
therefore what we're actually seeing is
people are buying it for 35 000 or right
this month mostly because of the crypto
guys this particular uh model of Rolex
is going way down because they're
selling it because they need to afford
rent and by the way if anybody wants to
do the the nft guy uh you know for for
crypto uh you know we'll hire you for
the bill card we'll pay you to build
this account
um if you're good so so so basically
this is the trend okay so why do I think
this works number one
the the value proposition is in the name
you don't even need to click to the bio
they're a walking billboard for what
value they're going to provide to you
what what they're going to teach you
about
I think that sets them apart from just
like oh this is Steve uh you know Steve
Irwin you you know you don't know that
he's the nature guy right like you don't
know that you have to there's still a
leap of faith you have to click in read
the bio then you get the VA then you
understand the value here it's right on
top second thing they promise basically
Data Insights and Industry secrets and
people really like Industries and so you
can go viral with some of these like
here's the dirty little secrets about
buying a used car or go about what
happens when you walk into a car
dealership I sat in these rooms for 30
years I know what conversations the bot
the seller is having when you walk in
like a fish and it's like I gotta click
this I gotta read this and at the end of
it I'm gonna trust them as a niche
expert
um so I think those are the two kind of
like core reasons that it works it's
also just a focused feed so versus my
account sometimes you're going to hear
me talk about sports I'm gonna crack a
joke I'm going to complain about my kids
and sometimes I'm going to Tweet Tech
stuff and in reality people just kind of
want you for one of those things at up
front up front a focused feed is going
to do better so I think that's why these
are these are working and um and I think
all of these people who do this are
going to make at least low millions of
dollars and a few of them who really
learn how to capitalize capitalize on
this or will make tens of millions of
dollars of a business that basically the
core of their business is just this
Twitter account where they are the um
you know the gas station guy like I said
it was mobile home park guy tweeted one
interesting thing about mobile home I
insta followed I have no real desire to
buy a mobile home park but I kind of
want to know about it be smarter about
it and then turns out the guy dmgs it's
my friend I'm like you you do this and
he's like yeah I was like what the
hell's going on here and so you know you
never know what's going on because your
dad your dad's doing the side hustle I
uh I think this is a really really good
Insight that you've had um and I
completely agree I think someone like a
caught the car guy I think could make
tens of millions of dollars now let me
give you now let me give you the so what
what I do about this let me add to it
right so by the way another good thing
about this you can have ghost riders or
contributors because you're just under
this Anonymous umbrella brand
um so it's that's another benefit here
um okay so what can you do with it so
first I think
avoid the
you know let me do shout outs let me do
paid ads in a free newsletter let me do
a community like if somebody says the
word Community you should stiff arm them
in this if you're doing these you got
like you want to do it where it's just
something you actually get towards the
transaction uh maybe a high ticket
course can work but like I do think you
want to be more like the car dealership
guy who's actually doing this or you
want to be the strip mall guy and you
want to raise a giant fund off of that
well dude have you asked why because I'm
the same way I would I almost sold my
car recently and I had him give me a
quote on it to tell me how much they're
selling for and then I go oh I and I
made a hundred thousand dollar plus
decision because of his advice have you
asked yourself why do we trust us these
guys like they don't even they use a
cartoon it's the same reason people
trust us from this podcast or from
Twitter which is that I think when you
get to see somebody think out loud which
is what writing is or talking on a
podcast
um and they're not talking to you you're
overhearing them and they're not selling
you anything they're just giving give
give give give right this is the garyvee
Playbook right the jab jab jab Hook is
give give give ask and so that's what
they're doing right now they're just in
give mode and I think that's the
absolute right way to be give give give
give insights inside and then there's a
surprising number of wealthy people who
will say hey can you help me I want to
do this I want to buy one of these or I
want to get your opinion on this and
they will come to you hat in hand like
me and you did to these suckers like
suckers to these guys okay so that's the
first thing
um
secondly I think that I would get away I
called it the guy Mafia but I'm calling
it right here it's time to start the gal
Mafia we need we need car dealership
lady we need strip strip club Queen we
need we need the female version MLM
Queen yeah exactly we need the uh it's
called Uh network marketing or some [__]
like that by the way that's how that
it's like when you meet somebody who's
proud of being in an MLM you're like
wait you know you're an MLM they're like
yeah I'm like I'm great at Network sales
so what the [__] is Network sales
if you can say the word I have a down
line like if those words have come out
of your mouth yeah yeah
that's what the that's what the Twitter
profile should be like does does the
word downline make you weak at the knees
if yes you're at the right place my
friend right if I presented you the
shapes circle square and triangle and
you're you immediately gravitate towards
triangle
it's like those like psych tests
whatever
um
okay so I think you should brand it as a
woman whether you're a guy or a girl to
be honest with you
um I think you know catfish away go I
think I think that's the first
opportunity
um second yeah you'll find all the
valuable niches so luxury watch sneakers
cars gas stations real estate I mean
what else this franchise is there's dude
but are women using Twitter I surveyed
my audience and I go select if you're a
male or a female and it was it was 93
male it was all dude there's probably
all dudes looking for a father figure
like it was all young men are are like
have you when me and sahil did the meet
up it was like uh literally a hundred to
one men to women it was crazy if you're
a single woman you've got to come to our
meetups you will love it
um do you have any women followers you
think like it's or it's all Twitter this
way
no I think it's more us than it is all
of it I think Twitter probably skews but
not to the 90 uh that's like that's kind
of a crazy ratio there but okay by the
way so here's here's my crazier ideas
okay so first of all I think Twitter's
the wrong place to do this um I think it
works on Twitter for sure but I also
think LinkedIn I think that there are
other networks where you should probably
be able to do well with this
um I don't know if LinkedIn allows like
Anonymous accounts or like fake names
maybe it doesn't but the second thing is
honestly I think there could be a whole
social network that's basically just yo
you join here and there's just verified
like people who are industry insiders
that you get to read their content from
And subscribe and follow them I think
you could literally like it is not
likely to work
but it's more likely than a lot of
stupid social app ideas because it has
really clear value prop so anyways
that's my like long shot idea around
this
yeah I think this is a really really
good Insight that you've had and I
completely agree that there's a massive
opportunity here I tried to make the
argument this Summer that there's going
to be a billion dollar Empire started on
Twitter just like there has been on
YouTube and all these other things and I
think one of these people it wouldn't
it's not out of this world that one of
these folks could be that person another
thing that I've noticed on Twitter and
um I didn't entirely plan this but
because you brought up I'll bring it up
have you noticed
um people doing Affiliates for agencies
so basically
um who
well a question that you and I probably
get asked a lot is like who's a good
accountant accounting firm or who's a
good growth marketer for newsletters or
uh you know there's like eight questions
that you and I get asked all the time
um and I did this with my body tutor so
my body tutor they were like hey do you
just want to like earn money every
person you send to us because you're
already sending tons of people I go hell
yeah give me a link I'm reading a bunch
of like a bunch of shout outs I was like
are you getting uh Kickbacks here or
what's going on I feel like you've
tweeted I haven't I just started doing
it for my body tutor because they're
like dude you send us so much like we'll
just give you some money if you want but
no I've I've not uh who have I tweeted
out lately I just I just call out
published them and it was one other one
that I saw that I was like uh Jason it
was your uh oh Diego my video guys yeah
yeah no no I no I just like I'm just
like [__] it dude you've done well what
I told him was I go hey if you're good
he does it for free right I go do it for
free for me and if you're good I'll tell
people about you and so I made them do
it for free for me for six months months
and so and so I was just like I'll just
share you with you but then you and I
have friends and I've seen people do
this and I think they're making hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year by
referring people to certain agencies and
the right way to do this is to find a
product or service that you're already a
fan of and ask for an affiliate or go
and start the thing with someone and
just be an affiliate and uh I think that
there's like this world we had Neil
Patel on the Pod and he basically
founded an agency and the reason why he
was considered the founder was he did
start it but he wasn't running it but a
lot of the early leads and probably a
lot of the leads to this day came from
neilpatel.com because people were using
his website to search like SEO stuff and
we haven't seen people do that on
Twitter but it actually is really good
because Twitter unlike the other social
media platforms is ideal for link clicks
and that makes it really easy to
attribute growth and I think that
there's a lot of people making a
significant amount of money referring
people to these high ticket products and
I think we can continue to see that it
might be a lot pretty quite big I've
thought about doing this so one thing
I've been thinking about doing is post
milk Road okay we sold the milk grow got
some time
what do I want to do next I kind of want
to focus on the Pod make the Pod bigger
uh better all that all that good stuff
one of the ways I think but the Pod you
know the Pod itself is free if you're
listening to this right now you've paid
me you know 0.0 so how does this ever
you know become something that that you
could justify saying I'm not gonna go
build another business I'm gonna do this
instead and one way is that can the Pod
basically provide some kind of win-win
value for people and so this one thing I
was thinking about was like I kind of
want to buy
a bunch of businesses that like of
people that I've worked with like either
you know like go to my accountant or go
to my lawyer or go to my estate planner
and basically buy the majority stake in
their firm
and in exchange be like cool there are a
lot of other Founders like me who also
want
estate planning who also want legal help
who also want trademark help who also
want accounting and basically just build
a MFM style like back office
um set of businesses and instead of an
affiliate like actually own them make
sure that they're they're great like
trust in them and
um
and then drive a bunch of value to the
to those businesses and then in return
there's a bunch of people Founders like
me who are constantly asking for
recommendations about like yo I'm trying
to find a good blank and I've burned
through seven accountants before I found
one I like same thing on the estate
planning side same thing and so it's
like not everybody should have to redo
that work and so that's one thought I've
had as to like a cool business to build
that just kind of helps kind of founder
entrepreneur you know types
um
and yeah just like own those own a
collection of those businesses that and
then uh you know have audience you know
people in this audience who want that
want those same Services be able to just
go find who we use
yeah and the the cons are like
can you possibly vet the right people
and have like actually quality but the
pros are like this is pretty much what
Richard Branson did with Virgin and so
it's definitely possible I often wonder
why like more celebrities like the
Kardashians and stuff like why don't
they own an equity stake in more things
than they do it doesn't seem like they
do for a lot they have done for one or
two things that ended up being quite big
and so I wonder like what's the strategy
like where's where does because every
celebrity has thought about this too and
so I think like well where's the down
where's the uh
you know how much how many if you're
gonna take Equity Stakes you know how
much how many things can you promote and
how many things can you you know you're
better off basically in those cases like
you're better off finding the one or two
product categories that you can own a
large chunk of and go big right this is
like skims for for Kim Kardashian this
is Kylie's lip stuff this is Conor
McGregor's whiskey Irish whiskey it's
like you know he took the Irish whiskey
things like I'm just going to put this
on blast I'm going to own a chunk of
this I'm going to put this on blast I
think they sold it for 500 600 million
um within three years something like
that so you know that was like worth a
lot more than like affiliate linking out
to 20 services or trying to own tiny
chunks of 20 businesses and then have to
use your clout to promote 20 different
businesses that's kind of exhausting so
I think that's why
you want to do a different topic yeah I
um let me brainstorm or do you want to
go to is there painful payment really
good
both of my things here I think are
pretty good but I can save them because
they're going to the end go go go go all
right which one do you want painful
attainment yes or the katana store the
katana store is a horrible name so what
is that actually I don't know I've seen
this is this the guy who keeps tweeting
about his YouTube page yes yes I thought
that was beautiful it I kept I'm like
wait Katana is this a joke like you
literally just sell swords yeah exactly
okay so I see this guy I've been I've
been seeing this guy for a while now and
so he's same I think his website's
called mini katana.com so it's mini
katanas but what does that mean like a
Tech Deck like a like a like a Tech Deck
but a sword
it was a Tech Deck I don't know what
that is remember the midi finger
skateboards oh no it's not that tall
it's like you know like two feet in
length instead of like a full samurai
sword is like you know five feet or
whatever uh this is this is uh you know
like half the size of a normal thing
maybe you know two feet instead of four
I didn't know this I didn't know the
standard size of a katana yeah I
realized I said that and like you know
the katana guy is gonna come after me
here and that's not who you want on your
bad side all right so if you go to this
website
you'll see that it does about one to two
million monthly visits which is a lot
that is a lot of traffic for an Ecom
store uh I he tweets about their revenue
sometimes wow the website is actually
awesome it's like the Supreme of like
swords yeah actually that's a good
that's a good thing so I think this
business does it does he said eight
figures it does at least 10 million a
year in Revenue I think I would get
closer to 20 more
um so I think it's probably closer to 20
based on the traffic and one of the main
ways that they do it is through YouTube
okay so really there's two kind of like
hardcore takeaways that I have out of
this so this I'm calling my um
I'm calling this my new Theory my
updated theory on what it takes to have
a great Ecom brand
by the way these are dope I'm gonna buy
me a [__] sword these are yeah you
went from making fun of this to add to
cart in like six seconds okay so yeah
I'm gonna buy me a gold sword who
doesn't I call this these stranger
things law which is basically if you
want to make it an Ecom one of the
things you got to do is find people who
are strangely and unapologetically
obsessed with a certain lifestyle and
then you just need to sell them things
so uh so you know that's that's the
whole model right so here's an example
Katana store right so it's like you have
this people you have people who are just
obsessed with Japanese culture for some
reason and they're always
being guy who loves Japanese culture
right
you're finding white people who are
super into Japanese culture not Japanese
people and uh and so you're like um and
and there's people who are really into
something that's kind of irrational and
I remember me one time I met this guy
who was the first product guy first
product manager at Twitter he joined
when Twitter was maybe like 10 15 people
uh total and I was like I remember
talking to him and I was like so was it
obvious at that time Twitter was going
to be huge he goes no no like Twitter
was it was like basically nothing at the
time it was very small it was just kind
of this thing that tech people were
doing but even the tech people who were
using it kind of felt like well this is
stupid right like we're all just text
messaging what we're like what we're
having for lunch right now like that
doesn't seem like the next big thing
and he goes but luckily I had learned a
very valuable lesson which is Anytime
You observe a weird Behavior people
doing a phenomenon where people are in
Mass just doing this thing that makes no
sense
I first your first reaction is say
that's weird and you kind of Judge it
because but I've learned you got to lean
into that phenomenon if people are doing
playing video games there's a reason
exactly this reminded me of my
experience when I was in college I
remember freshman year of college I walk
into my buddy tofiq's dorm room and I
was like
I see him playing video games and he's
got his back to me he's playing uh I
don't know Starcraft at the time I think
and then I'm like yo Toph and then he
turns around and I'm like oh sorry I
didn't like I didn't realize you're in a
game and because he took off his
headphones he turned around and I
noticed that the game is like still
going
and he's not he's not touching the mouse
anymore and I was like what are you wait
what are you doing what are you just
like like a demo mode what is this he
goes oh no I'm not playing I'm watching
you know your watch this 2010 I'm like a
2000 uh no 2007 or something like that
2008 and um I'm like you're watching
somebody play video games and he goes
yeah I have all I always do this I am
like you woke up I was like it's 8 30 in
the morning you woke up at 8 30 in the
morning and started watching somebody
play Starcraft why don't you just play
he's like no this is this is like one of
the best players I just want to watch
him
and I was like
nerd
I was like hold on let me go get four
friends so we can make fun of you
together because this is not gonna be
fun alone
I was like come see what trophy is doing
this guy's literally I was like do you
know is this your friend he's like did
you start like making fun of them but
you actually like sit next to me like
well hold on hold on let me like my
wife's doing that with a dragon you know
yeah
wait why did you go left you should have
you should have got left he went right
he's like yeah this guy is the best
player on the Korean server so they they
played this match last night Korean time
whatever I'm watching it now and I was
like you are the weirdest nerd and but
this guy is the weirdest guy uh you know
he he does like many many weird things
this is one of them and I remember just
laughing at him making fun of him fast
forward 10 years
I go and I I'm like announcing and our
uh LinkedIn or whatever like hey we sold
our company bibo to Twitch super excited
joined the exec team at twitch hey I get
this call from Tiffany Tiffany calls me
uh you know twice a year I get this call
from topek I pick up I'm expecting
correct congratulations it just goes you
little [__]
and he's like you used to make fun of me
for this [__] and now you're Mr twitch
and I was like oh yeah that's right I
forgot about that dude you were way
ahead of the curve I should have
listened to you like I could have
created twitch if I had like if I had
leaned into this Insight that people
want to watch other people in video
games I love a guy who holds a garage
for 10 years by the way dude he was he
was ready I like the cut of your jib guy
I'm about it and so anyways that that's
kind of the the the
learning of if you see people doing The
Stranger Behavior right like I remember
seeing people wear those Vibram five-toe
shoes where you're like you're gonna run
Barefoot why do you do that like yo and
they're like super into that lifestyle I
saw a video of Joe Rogan talking about
people who hunt white bucks or some [__]
like that like you know some certain
type of deer I guess it goes dude people
don't realize how crazy this lifestyle
is and he started explaining that people
will build
fields
of like food and like Lounge areas to
try to attract these bucks in to hunt
they like spend months building these
like you know demand caves for bucks
just to attract them and then they hunt
them right and I was like that's crazy
that I bet there's people who are
getting people getting cold ice baths
every morning people ice bats every
morning just like you people who um I
met a guy yesterday makes five million
dollars doing a woodworking course
and it's like why because people who are
into woodworking are not just kind of
into woodworking you can only be really
into woodworking and um so this is crazy
if you see the strange obsession that is
the basis for a store
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most trms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
so that's the first thing second thing
these guys are crushing it with YouTube
organic content they built their YouTube
channel up to 2 million subscribers oh
my God this is one of those like really
cool growth acts I think it's worth
going and looking at where they just do
these unboxings they got like you know
like cute girls who were into katanas
like nerding out about katanas as they
unbox them it's like yeah I can see a
bunch of dudes getting really into this
channel that makes sense to me like I
think that's gonna be like I think
there's a lot of people who are going to
like this brand and like this content
there and so I think they're just doing
a really good job I think it's good
really good execute like 10 out of 10
execution at like a 5 out of 10
opportunity
um but like you know still nonetheless a
lot you can kind of learn from this dude
I'm looking at their YouTube I don't
understand a lot of these references
because it's like anime based but they
don't do that many videos it looks like
they do one or two a month and they all
kind of hit they also do I think a lot
of tick tocks maybe so I think they do
they do tick tocks they basically just
move their Facebook ad budget into
hiring a full-time female Creator to do
this content and that sort of thing and
so uh yeah I think they're it's it's a
really cool really cool brand so I just
wanted to give the guy a shout out
because I figured his name but on
Twitter he's like showing all the back
end like he's taking screenshots of
their YouTube and he's a really really
good follow he's really been fascinating
I forget his name too
I'll find it but he said something like
um he said something like they uh they
got something like two or three hundred
million views in the last year and they
only started this past year uh and he's
like we're getting 80 million a month
Isaac what's this his name is Isaac he's
the Isaac Med MBD and his bio says
scaling a sword brand to nine figures
with Organic video marketing
well if that ain't exactly what we just
described you know like perfect
description yeah he did a really good
job he's really cool also I like his
profile picture a lot he kind of looks
like a madman he did like a good clear
headshot
but he kind of looks like a madman
instead of like a tryhard and I just
appreciate anybody that's not a tryhard
by the way pet peeve
I feel like all of Twitter is so cringe
and try hard
and I don't know if anything changed or
I changed but do you feel this way like
I feel like 90 of tweets and including
my own tweets I'm like is there a tweet
that's not cringy
I think that we were the tryhards and
now we're over it and we're making fun
of people that are doing the exact same
thing that we did
yeah I love that you you use the ladder
climb up and then you pull the ladder up
behind you yeah yeah I think that's what
we're doing you know when I did it it
was cool but when you do it that small
boy stuff
I think I think we're just uh being
haters which is cool uh which is fine
it's it's a natural it's a natural thing
let me uh explain I'll wrap up with one
quick thing
um I posted a researcher job so
basically I don't really have a
researcher you do and I'm envious of
that I want that I need a little help
because you're you're you always come
with fire I need a little help coming up
with good content for the Pod and by the
way if you want to see the job just go
to my Twitter and like scroll down
you'll see like a Google form but so I I
tweeted this out
I got like 300 applicants and in order
to apply I was very specific I was like
if you screw up one thing on these
directions like I'm not even going to
consider hiring you I was like you have
to like put your LinkedIn here job
application
well yeah because I was like dude if
you're not gonna split the details on
this then you're not gonna that's what I
said if you don't do a good job on this
I I don't believe you'll do a good job
on anything else and I made people I was
like I was like really simple come up
with three ideas and make it in a Google
doc and put the Google Doc Link in this
form make it so it's readable so I can
just click it if it's not readable I'm
not even gonna ask to like uh I won't
even look at it and um I got hundreds of
applicants about half of them followed
directions and about a good chunk 25
were actually pretty legitimate what do
I do with like these hundred like
decent people you know it's kind of like
an interesting this is like an
interesting business problem or a
business an interesting problem if you
have people so we did this with
Apartments so our my first business that
was an online company was basically look
in San Francisco an open bedroom for a
1200 a month apartment uh an open
bedroom and a three bedroom house that
gets like 500 applicants and all 500 are
interested in living in the same
neighborhood they're all interested in
this ad so they clearly have similar
interests we should just group them into
their own thing and move them into their
own apartment that was the premise of my
first company with this I'm like man I
got like 300 people 100 or are somewhat
qualified what do you do with this group
of people if I can it seems like such a
waste that I'm just using one of them
you know what I mean yeah unfortunately
not a lot of people need a researcher
like this so I think you just need to
translate it to like something like most
people don't have a podcast that
requires researching random business
stuff so what could these people do
that's what's a job that's more common
that these people would be really good
for
is it Like Chief of Staff type roles is
it like something like that you think
I don't know I I have I just started
thinking about this ahead of time uh
like right before we started recording
but I did think this is like the uh the
uh the application process is and this
is just a little small thing imagine if
you're uh Burger King or something or
some huge company and you get like you
know a million applicants a year uh it's
like kind of interesting where if you
you can only hire a couple of them and
so you're like are wasting 98 percent
you know in the same way that Ford
decided to make charcoal out of their
burnt wood that they were using to heat
their furnaces when they were making
iron can I what can my charcoal be of
these 299 applicants that I don't
actually hire
yeah that's a great question
um
I don't have an answer I don't have
anything I'm sorry yeah sorry people
like this is the letdown but yeah it's
an interesting question the thing to do
would be like what what common job do
these skills translate to and then you
have now a cohort or a pool of people
that are you know somewhat vetted that
you could create like a job board or
some sort of like matching Marketplace
or service where people could just hire
you know people like this for for that
common job but uh I'm not sure well I
wonder like like the people who have
enough probably don't care but but like
the people who like the the engineering
companies or some someone who's getting
like a startup that's getting an
engineering company or getting Engineers
to apply what they should do is just
like be like hey I'm sorry you didn't
get the job but here's like five other
gigs that are kind of cool and just take
like the thirty thousand dollar referral
fee do you know what I mean so our buddy
Ryan Hoover kind of did this he he was
hiring in a researcher or like an
analyst for his fund and he's like dude
I got like hundreds of applicants I've
interviewed them and he's like these I
forgot how many let's call it 30 just
for an example he's like these 30 were
really good I just I can't hire 30. I
only needed one and so he emailed me and
a bunch of other people who had funds
he's like do you need an analyst like
here's our kind of vetted analyst that
we thought were good
um if you need one like I'd love to help
these people get a job like he wasn't
asking for any money because Ryan's a
nice guy and you know this is not how
he's looking to make money but like it
was kind of great at the same time I was
sort of like
I'm not looking for the sloppy seconds
like these these people weren't good
enough for you why are they good enough
for me there's a part of me that's like
that too so I think you have that
challenge if I'm a tech company I'm
looking for engineers that's fair and I
hire these people and you didn't hire me
but you know Facebook didn't hire you
but Google should I think Google's got a
little problem with that so you have to
find somewhere around there that's fair
signal problem uh same thing with
Investments if I send an investment to
you I'm like hey great deal not doing it
though you should you you should invest
in this it's like those are the worst
those are the worst emails because it
just sometimes it's true it's like oh
this is just your Niche or it's your
stage or whatever
but a lot of times it just adds like a
negative flag to it for no reason
well and the answer to this might be
there's nothing I could do [__] them
sorry guys like you gave me you did all
this work for me and you're just not
you're not gonna get the job and there's
some guys who have applied for like
eight jobs that I've had throughout the
years and I feel so sad I'm like sorry
yeah you missed again we're not hiring
that many people right so it's just a
hard hard thing to do
um
all right let's wrap it up there
good episode and uh yeah we'll see you
guys
[Music]